Chỉ phụ anh, tổng bố khoản đấu tương xa hàng kỳ lúc chỉ 3 năm tỉ và ngành
tự đường hơn 20, 20, 20, 20, 20, dành cho nghiên cứu và phát triển.
Đây là phải uống trợ lớn nhất từ trời đến nay trong lĩnh vận này.
Năm trong kế hoạt đấu tự tổng thể, tả miếc sống tỉ và ngành,
gió bộ tại chính anh cố bố.
Khòn vốn, si đa phần bộ cho các thức quan nghiên cứu chủ chốt.
Như các quan nghiên cứu và đổi người anh, các quan nghiên cứu và phát mình tình tiến,
các quan khí tựa của sai và việc an ninh chỉ tuyện nghiên tạo.
Một tiêu của chính trình là túc đầy cơ đột phát qua học hỗ trợ đổi mối sản tạo
và cù cố vỉ thì anh cho các lĩnh vật tông nghệ mới nổi.
Chỉ phụ anh ở tình, mối bản anh đấu tư công vào nghi tử,
xem anh lại tả bản anh giá chỉ tình tế và tù mối tìm hai bản anh từ cú bực tương nhận
gó phần tạo nên tảnh vững chắc cho tăng trường xa hàng.